we're now going to look at some examples
of matrix vector uh
matrix vector multiplication by the way
we'll see it throughout the rest of the
course so these are just think of these
as just your first
examples that you're seeing however they
should already kind of be clear that
it's going to do something that is going
to be useful for us
okay so we start with some really dumb
stuff you know the basics okay so
if i multiply a zero matrix by any
vector i get zero
right and so i mean you look at the
equation zero x equals zero and your
eyeball says yeah sure what else was it
going to be
but it's important to understand that
this is we're actually loading into
these four characters
that's quite a strong statement right 0
is a matrix x is a vector and
0 here is a vector
here's one that identity matrix i don't
know if you remember the identity matrix
it's a matrix with
ones on the diagonal like this and zeros
everywhere
off the diagonal right so something like
that there's there
there you go there's a there's a four by
four identity matrix if you multiply
that by any vector
you get the vector back and that's by
the way it's called an identity matrix
right
it it does absolutely nothing if you
multiply it by a vector and as it gives
you the same vector back
and you can you should check that i mean
let's just multiply this by
you know x1 x2 x3 and x4
and let's just audit this let's just
take let's do the third
let's fill in what the third r what the
third entry
in in this case i x is well
that says please walk across that column
right that row i'm
sorry and go down here and you you
basically you you multiply zero by x one
zero by x two
one by x three zero by x three you
multiply that you're going to get x
three so you get x three here
okay and you know sure enough x3 is the
third
entry of this and it's the third entry
of that and okay i mean that was
silly but the point is you should do
this to just check
you know okay um all right
now the inner product from basically
part one of the course on vectors uh
we wrote it as a transpose b
um as i said last time i misspoke on a
number of occasions and accidentally
referred to it as a transpose b
that was bad because in fact we had not
i have not defined what a transpose was
or anything like that so
most of the time i think i got it right
and referred to a transpose b as the
inner product
henceforth though i'm fully allowed to
refer to a transpose b
either as the inner product of a and b
the two vectors
or literally a transpose b which means
transpose a which makes it a row vector
and multiply it
matrix vector multiplication by b okay
so
uh that's it and it's nice it means that
it explains that notation
fully it's nothing new it's nothing
special um
okay and so it's really cool it says
take an n vector
form when you transpose it it becomes a
n row vector and then you multiply
by the n vector b and the result by the
way is a one by one matrix which we just
consider to be a number
okay so our notation is completely
consistent with
transpose and vector matrix vector
multiplication are completely consistent
and in fact are exactly are
our notation for the inner product okay
let's look at some other ones here's an
example
you recall what it means to demean a
vector to d mean a vector says take x
take the average of all of its entries
and subtract that number from every
single entry
in a okay and what that means
of course is you know the new vector is
kind of the same as the old one
except now the the the the except the
mean of all the entries are zero
or something like that okay the mean of
yeah all right so
that is accomplished with x tilde equals
uh ax where this is the matrix this is
the matrix so we can
we can even sort of see that that's
right so let's look at x1
down to xn here and multiply this
well and let's say that we we believe
that that's x tilde one
and let me see what it is let's just
check that first entry
x tilde one is going to be this number
times x one plus this number times x two
all the way up to that and that's gonna
be this x tilde 1
is equal to now the 1 minus 1 over n if
you don't mind i'm going to write it
this way i'm going to write it as x 1
minus 1 over n x 1. it's weird but
that's what i'm going to do
minus 1 over n x 2 and then this goes on
for a while and then i have
minus uh 1 over n times
xn hey look at that
this is negative is the negative of the
average so in fact this is right
you can you can check so this is a fancy
way
it's a silly way to demean a vector but
you can think of it as just a matrix
vector multiplication with this matrix a
yeah by the way um in these connections
when we see what multiplying by a matrix
to a vector does um
and we interpret it some way like this
is this is d meaning
um you're going to want to establish
develop the skill
of going both ways like i show you a
matrix and then you tell me what it is
in words
i mean if it's just some weird random
matrix the answer is i don't know but
the point is
you should be you i should have been
able to give that matrix and say
what does it do and then you would come
back and say
oh it's simply subtracts the mean of the
entries
from every entry of x it's a d mean
people would even refer to that as the d
meaning matrix so
anyway and you'll want to go back and
forth so we'll get to that later
okay here's a here's a matrix uh which
illustrates what i was just talking
about
perfectly um it's a n minus 1 by n
difference matrix here's d it's very
sparse right by the way most of the
entries are
zero a few entries are minus one and
some are plus one so here here's what it
looks like
it says it says minus one you know one
then the next entry is
then all zeros zero minus one one
and what happens is we simply put a
vector here
multiply this out and and see
what we think uh what happens okay
so when i multiply this row by this
if i if i do this row by this
this vector here what i'm going to get
is minus
x1 that's from this entry plus x2
and then everything else is 0. so what
you're going to get is this
dx is x2 minus x1 then x3 minus x2
because of this
here and and so on
and you get n minus one of these and you
can see what this matrix does
it takes the first difference the
difference if
if x is a vector it simply takes
the difference of consecutive entries
right
so now by the way a lot of times if if
the feature if these were just
x's that are if the different entries of
x are features
and they have no relation to one another
this has no meaning and no use
but for example if x is a time series
this
is super interesting right so if x is
the rainfall uh
over at a different day on different
days then
dx tells you the change in rainfall
from a given day uh well from tomorrow
from today or something you know the
change the one the daily change in
rainfall is what it does
if it is positive it means there was
more rain
on that day than yesterday if it's
negative it means it was less
okay so you could even if you like you
could even start thinking in the back of
your mind that this is something like a
derivative
right or something i mean don't take
that too seriously but it's something
like that
okay so so that's a matrix you will see
this
many many many many many times and uh
it's you might as well just get used to
it right now it's a difference matrix
and and we should have been able to do
this with you from you know both ways
right that i should have showed you that
matrix and said what does it do
and eventually you could have said it
takes the
it takes the consecutive differences
right um
so here's something that comes from that
it's a beautiful thing it's the norm
squared of the of dx
and that's called the dirichlet energy
dirichlet was a mathematician
and it's a measure of the wiggliness for
x of x as a time series because
you know what this thing is this is
exactly equal to the sum
of x i minus
x i minus 1 squared
and the sum goes from i equals 2 to n
that's what it is so it's literally the
sum of the squares
of the consecutive differences so you
could have dx the dirichlet energy is
zero
for any vector which is quote constant
meaning
all the entries are the same then the
dirichlet energy is zero
if x is like crazy wiggly
or you know first it's plus ten minus
ten might plus you know if it's if it's
alternating sign
the dirichlet energy is going to be very
high right so that's
that's that's the idea behind that that
that's going to come up
later in the class uh exactly this kind
of thing
okay here's another example
this one is from finance so let's let r
be a t by n matrix of asset returns
right and so uh the rows
represent time periods consecutive time
periods or
let's say dates the trading days right
and the
columns represent a particular asset and
we have a universe of n
assets that is the slang that you would
refer to the set of assets you're
looking at
let's say at a quantitative hedge fund
you'd say what what's your universe and
in this case n
is the size of the universe of assets
okay
um and so rij is the return of asset
i sorry it's a return of asset j in
period
i okay um let's look at an n vector w
and it gives a portfolio
um and it gives you let's say the
investments in the assets um they could
add up to one in which case it tells you
the proportional investments like you
know i put ten percent of my portfolio
is in asset one twenty percent in asset
two
it can even have negative numbers which
represents short positions
um negative ownership i think we talked
about that before it's weird but
it's possible and then
rw literally by sticking the matrix
times the weights
um what what you will get is a vector
of the time series of your portfolio
return
okay so um i mean it's really cool
right so uh i mean we could just do a
quick example right so
i'm not going to work everything out
because it's kind of goofy
i'll do the let's see okay this is 0.02
minus 0.01 you know i'm just going to do
a couple here
.03 and minus 0.04
you know and i don't know what this is
this is going to be 0.01
and 0.01 okay so here are this is
silly because it's so small but the
point is three time periods so three
trading days
two assets i don't know what they are
you know google and intel or
i couldn't care less right okay so here
are the two and then you know we
let's ask ourselves like what what does
it mean well the first column
gives you the time series of returns of
the first asset the second column gives
you time series of returns of
the second asset so for example the
second asset lost a percent
gained a percent then gained another
percent okay
the first asset gained two percent then
three
then minus then minus four percent okay
now
now i'm going to make a portfolio of of
these and i'm going to make it i'm going
to make it super simple because i don't
even want to mess with it
okay here's my portfolio it's going to
be
0.5 and 0.5
so i'm simply going to invest equally in
these two assets
okay and that's my that's what the 0.5.5
means
okay so uh it's the proportions that i
invest in it
and so let's see what what happens when
i get rw
when i multiply our w actually
interestingly what i'm getting is a
three vector
and it's this row times that and i'm
actually if you if you multiply by point
five point five
you're actually taking the average right
so the average of minus a point of two
up two percent and down one percent
is let's see it is uh down
it's plus 0.005 i hope i did that right
okay and the average of the other two is
going to be 0.02
i'll put the o there and the average of
these is uh
minus 0.04 and plus minus 0.03 divided
by 2
is maybe point minus 0.015
there we go um i made those up in real
time
i hope they're right if they're not
sorry uh
but in any case see that's the nice part
if i had a class in front of me
somebody would be could wave their hand
and say that's wrong and i would say
good thanks just checking on you but i
can't do that now so all right
um so let's see what it means it means
that if i invested equally in these two
here here would have been the sequence
of my portfolio returns
right so you know on the first period
i'd say oh good news your first asset
went up
two percent and you'd say bad news your
second asset went down one percent but
my portfolio went up half a percent
right on the second one
it'd be hey great news your first asset
went up three percent your second went
up one percent
i'm 50 50. so my portfolio goes up two
percent
okay so that's that's kind of the idea
okay
so that's it and now it's really cool so
when you do
matrix vector multiplication when w is a
portfolio
and r is this return asset returns
uh many assets many time periods what
you get is
you get the time series of the portfolio
return so
for example if i take the average of rw
that's literally the portfolio mean
return because this this is a this is
like a return
time series and if i take the standard
deviation that's the risk
right so so just just a handful of
things now we're able to
uh very quickly uh describe real things
right so if i have a return matrix and
so this way
for example uh we could can we could
discuss
different weight vectors somebody could
say
here's my weight vector someone says
where to come from and they could say
it's none of your business someone else
say here's
my weight vector and you'd say cool
we can then calculate for both of them
for both those weight vectors
what would be the return time series of
their portfolios
and then we can actually evaluate each
one on a mean
which is the mean return and on the
standard deviation
of that time series and that's going to
be the risk and
maybe they're incomparable but maybe one
is better that maybe one dominates the
other
dominates meaning that it has higher
return and lower risk
but so this is the idea but and look how
quick it's just in it's just
just a handful of concepts we have we're
just shoving them together
here's one a feature matrix and a weight
vector
so here what i do is i form a feature
matrix so the
columns of a feature matrix are the
features
for for the different items in this case
i have capital n items
and uh each one is an n vector i have n
features
and so i shove them together in a matrix
which i'm going to call the feature
metric matrix and so the columns
are going to be well the feature the the
future vectors
for the items okay here if i make
i've a w a weight vector and if i form
x transpose w let's be
super careful here x has size
n by n x transpose
has size n by n okay
and then we propose to multiply that by
an n vector
and that's cool so yeah i should mention
something here
you're going to want to turn on a syntax
checker well the same way any kind of
computer language has one but you need
to be one yourself it's a mathematical
syntax checker
you just want to make sure everything is
cool right
so i mean somebody might mess up and
write here xw
and but you should immediately that
should throw an alarm because you should
say
um excuse me hello whoa slow down here
you cannot multiply you know a little n
by capital n matrix by an n little n
vector
unless k unless they're equal right so
that's
you just want to be checking that the
syntax rule that the rules are
correct right so okay you know any more
than if i walked up down the street
and and said that two vectors a two
vector and a three vector are equal
right it just it just it doesn't conform
to syntax so you want to check
okay um so what you get in this case is
if i form this then this is basically
the same as taking the inner product
of each one of our feature vectors with
this weight vector
and we had interpreted that before
scores right so for example
each each of these each the items could
be
individual people x the x
i is for the i person it is a feature
it's a set of features that
characterizes that person and it should
be things like the total
amount of late payments on
her his credit card in the last six
months i'm just making this up okay
another one could be the
fraction of times they pay off their
whatever future
one one could be have they actually
declared bankruptcy in the last five
years
right something like that so i have all
sorts of features right uh
related to them um okay that's a feature
vector and then w
is some weight vector which i don't know
what it is and then this thing this
score
could be for it could could develop a
credit score right so it says here's the
credit score and in which case by the
way everything here is completely
interpretable
right so w1 for example tells you
how much does feature one figure in to
your credit score
and so for example if the first feature
is either zero or one
zero if that person has not declared
bankruptcy
in the last five years one if he or she
has
then we would expect w1 to be negative
meaning that if you
if a person has declared bankruptcy in
the last whatever five years
we would expect their credit score to be
lower uh than if they had not so
it's all perfectly interpretable but
once again
matrix vector multiplication with a
transpose in here
gets you uh get get gets you something
that's very interesting and
potentially already should be clear that
this is we're bordering on
if we're not already there useful
another beautiful interpretation of
matrix vector multiplication is just
input output
so there we simply write like y equals
ax
these are almost the traditional symbols
too you think of and what you do is you
think of x as an input or an action
and you think of y as an output or
outcome
or result okay and tons of examples of
this we will
we'll see a bunch of them but that's
kind of the idea and then you think of
like
matrix vector multiplication as simply
an action
what it does it's what it it it's it
maps the action
to the result okay so uh
and in which case we can have this very
simple you know generic interpretation
so for example aij that's the ij
entry that's the factor by which y
i depends on xj okay if it's zero it
means
doesn't depend on it if it's large and
positive it says that when x j goes up
um y i goes up if it's large and
negative it says that when x j goes up
uh y i goes way down right so that's
that's kind of the interpretation
oh here's an interesting one if the
matrix a is lower triangular
right then it says that y i only depends
on x one up to x i
okay and by the way if these are time
series is kind of awesome because
that means that that's like causality it
says that
you know the i the i f outcome which and
we think of i as a time period
it really can only depend on what x was
doing in time period i
which is now i minus one that's like
let's say it's daily that's yesterday
i minus two that's day before yesterday
and so on right so their
lower triangularity corresponds to what
you know causality basically
so that's this is the idea so this is
another interpretation we're going to
come to this many many many times
finally we're going to talk about the
complexity of some
of some of these matrix operations
meaning
how many flops does it take and again
we're going to approximate it grossly
because that's what people do
just to get a rough idea so okay so
first of all
m by n matrix a is stored on a computer
as an m by n array of numbers so
uh so you know i mean although an array
would be understandable to a
mathematician
um it's for it that's actually the
language of computer science and
computer languages
okay um i mean it's fine but you just
have to keep
two sets of two dialects i guess to
describe
the same thing and just make sure you
know which dialect you're speaking
okay um now for a sparse matrix uh it's
stored in a different way that you store
uh roughly speaking all you do is you
store the non-zero values and so you
would give a list with i
j and value okay so like a dictionary if
you're
familiar with that in some language
you're working on or there's other
exotic ways that people describe sparse
matrices doesn't matter
okay now first let's talk about the
simple ones right if i
add two matrices well that's silly i
just add up m
n numbers so that's mn flops
if i do scalar matrix multiplication
it's the same
i'm just i just i multiply that same
scalar by every
entry of the matrix and that's mn flops
how about matrix oh i should ask you
this how many flops is in the transpose
forming a transpose well i guess the
conventional
answer to that is zero because you don't
do any multiplications adds or anything
you're literally just moving entries
from one place to another
now the fact is it actually doesn't cost
zero time to transpose a matrix right
because
you know memory you have to access
memory and then move it somewhere else
and all that sort of stuff
so this just shows you one of the the
shortcomings of
a flop count um it's still however quite
useful uh the idea of a flop gun so
so summary on that weird discussion is
this
the complexity of forming a transpose is
well
zero it involves zero floating point
operations
no ads no subtractions no multiplies no
divisions no square roots
okay um let's look at matrix vector
multiplication
well let's figure that out um well we
could do it this way we could think of
it
this way it's it's actually calculating
for each
each row or each entry of the product
that's of which there's m we calculate
an inner product with a row of a
and x okay and that as you recall from
last time takes two n minus one multi uh
uh flops right it takes uh it takes n
multiplications and then n minus one
additions and so two n minus one
and the minus one we just get rid of and
we simply say that it's two m n flops
that's it um no by the way if a is
sparse you only have to multiply the
terms that involve non-zeros i mean of
course
right but this is it's two mn flops
right so uh just for fun
let's figure out let's do a real example
let's do a return matrix that has a
universe of
1 000 assets that's typical actually
that's kind of like you know somewhere
between s p
500 and some high cap us high cap okay
so we have a thousand assets
and let's let's give uh
i don't know let's go let's go i'll just
make it approximate but suppose i gave
you
um here i will give you one
i don't want to make it square i'm going
to give you
uh yeah i'll make it square sorry about
that i'm going to give you about a
thousand
trading days that's about four years
because you know there's about 250
trading days in a year so it's a
thousand by thousand
um by the way this looks you would say
oh my god that's got a million numbers
in it oh
whoa we're right it's the it's the
basically it's the return on any of a
thousand days
that's four years of a thousand
different stocks right so some column
here is google
and here's amazon right and here is july
uh 12th okay so that that's how this
works right so
you know it it looks scary it's a lot of
it's a lot of numbers a million numbers
is not a small number um
i mean this is hilariously small just
i'm sure
you knew i was getting there right that
i could do this on my phone but we're
going to figure out how long it takes to
do this multiplication
on my phone let's say okay and then now
i have a portfolio with a thousand
numbers right that's those are my
weights
who knows where the portfolio came from
it doesn't really matter
okay well the number of flops required
is going to be 2mn and that is 2 times
10 to the 6
flops okay now
but by the way it would take you if i
asked you to multiply this matrix by
this vector
it's going to take you a long time
because you're going to have to do 2
million floating point operations
right that's going to take you quite a
while okay to do
okay i mean that's of course the whole
point is you don't do that but whatever
okay so it's two million flops and now
i'm gonna say
uh how long does it take to do that on
my phone
we could do that you can do my phone my
laptop my laptop
let's do my laptop my laptop can do this
and with about
10 gigaflops per second so
on my laptop it would be 2 times 10 to
the 6
divided by 10 gigaflops a gigaflop is 10
to the 9 so this is 10 to the
10. and what you're going to get is
uh actually i'll tell you what you're
going to get you're going to get
this is going to be 10 to the minus 4 so
it is 2 times 10 to the minus 4 so
people would write that as 200
microseconds okay a microsecond is a
millionth of a second
okay so that says that
if you wanted to find the portfolio time
series
if someone proposes a weight vector it
says
i would like to hold these assets in
this thing for four years
please tell me what show me my my
portfolio returns you're multiplying r
times w
and that would take you a shockingly
small amount of time
so it would take you 200 microseconds
you could do this 5 000 times
in one second that's on my laptop so i
could evaluate 500
uh sorry 5 000 different portfolios
in one second on my laptop okay i'm just
giving you a rough idea right of what it
is but
the point is it's these are these are
fantastically big calculations being
done and they're done super fast